my wife and i were vegetarians at the
time there was a lot of roasted garlic
in everything it seemed like and that's
something that doesn't necessarily agree
with my system
we got on the flight and i was it was a
packed flight felt like the pressure
building up
gotta
so i decided what i would do is just let
it out a little bit at a time
so that it would dissipate and not be a
big deal but unfortunately it all came
out at once
just just the fart there's a guy sitting
behind me who fainted from your fart
yeah and his uh his girlfriend called
the flight attendants over somebody has
gas no no ma'am that's not possible all
of the fuel is stored on the wings
there's nothing i i fell asleep i woke
up again i farted again the guy faints
again they administer oxygen and again
his girlfriend says somebody has gas and
the woman sitting next to them and says
it's not a gas leak somebody has to go
to the bathroom and so we land the plane
and everyone has to sit in their seats
while paramedics come and get this guy
off if you're going to shoot your pants
he's saying
i don't know it's just something smells
so bad